the incredible bert wonderstone is it
incredible no this movie is the
definition of a film that plays it safe
it's a nice movie a polite movie it has
an intriguing premise a great world to
explore but its execution does not take
advantage of its potential on paper
everything sounds great steve carell is
a magician competing against jim carrey
but the movie plays it way too safe with
no real edge and when it tries being
edgy with its sexual humor most of the
time it felt like it didn't belong in
this movie it feels like a family film
with sex jokes but its job is to make us
laugh so how does it do in that
department well i cracked up enough
times to say it's a nice movie a polite
movie with sex jokes it certainly
doesn't have a magical touch there's
definitely some tonal issues the film is
not outrageous but the cast saves this
movie steve carl is at his best when
he's grounded steve buscemi's very
likable alan arkin is the best thing in
this movie james gandolfini is
surprisingly really funny still fat
olivia wilde did some solid supporting
work hey you know plus two i bang her
and jim carrey's funny i guess without
the actors being well cast for these
roles it would not have been as humorous
i'm not saying the movie's hilarious i'm
just saying there's enough funny moments
it's a nice sometimes funny movie with
sex jokes it would be better on dvd than
in the theaters because it's really not
worth spending twelve dollars and fifty
cents on but hey [ __ ] it i enjoyed
myself throughout i wasn't bored i was
always amused it had enough heart and
humor that won me over let me get
straight to the point here all in all i
gotta say the incredible bert
wonderstone got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
the video you can go ahead and tell me
your points below and if you liked the
video
go ahead and like the video and if you
want to see a more in-depth review of
the incredible bert wonderstone go ahead
and check out my show that i do with my
buddy jerry called reasons to see where
we give you reasons to see and not to
see the incredible bert wunderstone and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time a new video is out go
ahead and subscribe to my channel